as some of you know my mother died of an
overdose a few years ago after she died
I kept her stuff in two storage units
because I didn't want to get rid of
anything until my two brothers had a
chance to go through her stuff and see
if there's something they want to keep
maybe grab something to remember her by
later my brother John went to prison for
various drug charges my brother Manny
died of an overdose but I kept
everything in storage so JN could go
through it when he got out John gets out
of prison tomorrow he got parole so now
I'm going through the storage units
getting rid of some of the junk so John
can decide what he wants to keep and
look at
this this is about a quarter of the drug
related items I found I've been throwing
it away as I open bags and boxes but
then I thought maybe I'll make a short
video to warn people about the
consequences of their
decisions many of you who are watching
will have an opportunity to try
something like this at some point before
you take that first hit of heroin or
fenel or meth or whatever it may be just
know that this is what your life becomes
you don't want this to become your life
you just want to have fun or try
something new but this is where it
leads and this isn't life so learn from
the mistakes of others and choose life